10 considérés comme des illuminés les
cyclistes hivernaux font de plus en plus
partie du paysage dans les rues de
montréal
selon la firme éco compteur il y a eu 64
mille passages en janvier 2020 70 % de
plus que l'année précédente
françois des montagnes a créé la page
facebook vélo d'hiver montréal elle
compte aujourd'hui près de onze mille
membres deux fois plus qu'il ya quatre
ans vélo quatre saisons je pense qu'ils
aient eu à un point déclencheur quand on
a commencé à officiellement à déneiger
les pistes cyclables comme sur le
surloyer ou rachel ça fait un certain
temps de maisonneuve ça fait presque dix
ans mais là qui a commencé à avoir un
véritable réseau des pistes hivernale
donc les gens ont vu la cave et une
possibilité de continuer à rouler toute
l'année l'hiver dernier la ville
soutient avoir déneigé 76% du réseau
cyclable soit l'équivalent de 590 km
incluant les rues ou de simples bandes
de son père au sol 80 90 % l'hiver à
montréal en route sur l'asphalté malgré
tout quelqu'un qui commence me très bien
décider de premier hiver j'ai juste
rouler quand ce sera de l'asphalté il
reste du temps je prends le métro
ça marche ça mais oui c'est solide
le météorologue de radio-canada pascal
yiacouvakis se déplace à vélo depuis
cinq ou six ans et ce dix mois par année
y en a beaucoup qui pensent que la
première étape
l'année dernière ou interpréter neige la
rose novembre le poids des jeunes anti
maison est terminée
pas sûr parce que quelques jours après
la neige avait été chargé puis j'ai
roulé jusqu'à noël
les automobilistes s'ajuste de plus en
plus à ce nouvel achalandage et la
relation avec les cyclistes devient peu
à peu plus courtoise parce que de
mauvais aménagement créer des mauvais
comportements
à partir du moment où on crée un espace
dédié pour chacun il ya beaucoup moins
de conflits à partir du moment où même
aux intersections on a des feux de
circulation pour chacun ça réduit
beaucoup les conflits avec le nouveau
réseau express vélo il y a tout lieu de
croire que le nombre de cyclistes
augmentera encore cet hiver surtout que
beaucoup de citoyens craignent de
prendre les transports en commun en
raison de lakovic 19 pour les débutants
voici quelques conseils de nos experts
c'est trop dangereux c'est le froid
c'est impossible quand on [ __ ] en au
chaud alors c'est un peu comme le ski de
fond au sabé avec des couches pays à
tous ce salon la température on commence
à en voir quelques-uns des casques avec
une petite visia la rabattables donc
quand il pleut ça évite d'avoir les
gouttelettes de pluie dans les yeux ou
les flocons de neige
et puis a quand même de l'air qui
circule donc si on met un petit un petit
cache cou par dessus la ça permet
d'avoir les verts qui circule même temps
de se tenir au chaud
rappelez vous que les journées sont
courtes en hiver alors l'importance
d'avoir une lumière activent en avant et
en arrière c'est obligatoire dans le cas
de la sécurité routière mais c'est
surtout essentiel pour votre sécurité
michel chabot radio canada montréal